Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner said we are going to share some information about
supporting those of our patients that are doing chemotherapy and protocol that is
not set in stone. So as I go through this, understand that yours may be slightly different,
but I want to give you some understanding on why we're making some recommendations.
So I know that the number of my patients are choosing to do chemotherapy and we want to support
them in every way that they can. That's not the decision that we try to influence our patients
to do or not to do in either way. That's a decision between them and their loved ones and their
oncologist. We know that there's all sorts of negatives to doing chemotherapy. There could also be
positives as well. This little slide is from truth about cancer. The positives are that you
want the chemotherapy to kill the cancer. So that's what we want to address and how we want to
help support the patient. The longer the chemotherapy stays in the body, it really does its effect
on the cancer. And within the first 48 hours, the longer it stays in the body, that's what you start
to get worse and worse side effects because it enters into the cells, healthy cells and causes
injury to them as well. And that's what gives us our side effects. So we're going to walk through the
days prior to chemotherapy the day before chemotherapy, the day of chemotherapy, 48 hours post chemotherapy,
and then after the 48 hours. So you'll see as we go through this because the protocol is a little bit
different in each of those phases. So phase one we could say is starting two weeks prior to chemotherapy.
And this is taken from a protocol sheet that we've created that I will include as you could download
that we'll go with this video in the blog post. So I kind of up to show you here talk through our
recommendations and understand everybody's different. So this is just a guide. This is not something for
you to follow directly. So you want to communicate with us so that we can walk you through this.
So starting two weeks prior to the chemo dietary, we want you to stay on the diet that we
recommend it. So remember everybody's diet is different. So your diet might be low in glutamate,
immaturity, therefore low in protein, your diet might be more ketogenic-like, your diet might be
more mixed. So follow the diet that we gave you in your binder because we developed that via testing.
So we want to follow that same diet. Second, be very careful to limit sugar a little bit
stricter than you have two weeks prior to chemo. As well as any inflammatory foods like dairy,
and we've discussed addozium, why cancer patients shouldn't be eating a lot of dairy because it
stimulates ITF1 and M-tor production. And gluten because it's inflammatory, even though I didn't take
you, if I didn't take you off of gluten, decreasing gluten, two weeks prior to chemo or
state-off gluten will help decrease inflammation and will help you get through this chemo. It
haven't worked on your body to kill the cancer, not so many of your cells. In addition to this,
we want to add a few supplements. So if I don't already have you on liver and D, we want to add
that. That's a liquid supplement. And again, call our office about this. And then I want to add
phospholide. If I don't have you on phospholide, that's a phosphatidolcolyne. Two capsules a day
or PC-bio. That's just a liquid for a phospholide. They're the exact same product.
One's in a liquid for one's in a capsule for it. So do one teaspoon a day PC-bio. That stands for
phosphatidolcolyne or two capsules a day of phospholide. That would be the addition plus anything else
that we may recommend specifically for you. Therapies that you want to consider if you're local
and you can get to our office is to add PEMF twice a week, at least twice a week. Or if you get to a
clinic that has a PEMF near you, that would be a good therapy to start two weeks prior to chemo. So these
are all done two weeks prior to chemo. So I got chemo two weeks from today. This is what I would
begin. Then we move on to the next phase, the day before chemo. So the day before chemo, we're going to
change your diet. We want to go into 24 hour water fast the day before chemo. So let's say by chemo
tomorrow. So today I'm going to wake up and I'm not going to eat anything but drink water and take my
supplements throughout this day. But that's all I'm going to do. Water and my supplements. It'd be great
if you could do PEMF. It would be also, you would more great if you could also add hypothermia right
over the cancer. Now I understand if you're not here at clinics, chance you're fighting to place it as
hypothermia is like slim to zero. So if you're here at clinic, do eat hypothermia right over the
cancer would be fantastic. Water fasted prior to chemo has is a relatively new concept. Dr. Paul
Bragg in this book right here, I think this was published originally in the 60s, was the first one
to really put out information on a fast to the public in a way that it was easy to understand and read.
It's a great book. I had to have this in my library for the old cover for decades. Very good book. This does
not talk about cancer though. The longevity diet book by Evolter Lugo, he's the one who just recently has
really put fasting in the fasting mimicky diet on the map. He's a researcher with the University of
Southern California and he's been working with some natural ecologists in California that have tried
the fasting mimicky diet. This this topic is not of the fasting mimicky diet, we're talking about
just prior to chemo. And they found that using the fasting mimicky diet prior to chemo, but doing a
fewer 24 hour water fast the day before chemo and the day of chemo, so it's actually a 48 hour water fast
has is shown to decrease the side effects of chemo in the patients that did it by
50% or more. So that's extremely dramatic and that had nothing to do with them changing the diet
of the patient any other way. They didn't do anything else. They didn't do supplements. They just
simply had them do a water fast the day before the day of the cancer and literally 50% reduction in
symptoms. So that's worth it. Do we did? Therapies continue PEMF and hypothermia over the region
of the cancer would be fantastic. So this is the day before chemo. So remember this was two weeks
prior to chemo. This is the day before chemo. I have chemo tomorrow. I'm going to do a whole water
fast today. Continue by supplements, continue by therapies. The day of the chemo, continue doing a
water fast. So this would make 24 to 48 hours though when you finish that water fast, you go up two
days on a water fast, continue all supplements. If you could do PEMF, hypothermia, over the cancer
that would be fantastic. This is a real important one though. Upon returning home immediately after
you do your chemo session, begin running your personalized life programs. If you don't,
unless you got something you absolutely have to do, you have to get the kids to school or whatever
you're doing, try to run your that diet program. So I'm doing chemo on a Monday. Run your
Monday diet program. You'll run it right away for as many hours as you can. If it's only three hours,
then you've got to get up and make supper. Whatever you have to do, try to run as many hours as
you can on that right program because the right program is stimulating the cancer. If you have chemo
running through your veins, you want those cancer cells stimulated so it'll be more attracted to the
chemo. So it'll help the chemo target the cancer. Then of course you're going to run your
diet program. So it's very important that you get as much right time as you possibly can after your
chemo. So this is the day of the chemo. No. So the 22 weeks prior, the day before chemo, the day
of chemo, and now we're at 48 hours following chemo. So I had chemo two days ago. So between chemo
and two days, then this two days I'll go to where I met no, you're going to go back on the recommended
diet. So after you did those two days of fast, you're going to go back on your normal recommended
diet. You're obviously continuing your supplements. If you can't do PMF, if you can't do hypothermia,
you're obviously running your right program day and night. Still, during this 48 hours, if you
have an ion pro wave, or if you have an ion cleanse or have access to that and a practitioner's office,
do not run these programs for 48 hours after you do your chemo. We don't want to pull out. We don't
want to detox the chemo out of your body in this 48 hours. And doing the ion pro wave and doing
the ion cleanse will help tremendously to detox the chemo out of your body. But if you're going to go
and do chemo, we certainly don't want to detox it out of your body before it actually kills the
cancer. So we want that chemo to do its best job and kill you the cancer. So do not run ion pro wave,
do not run an ion cleanse, do not even do coffee enemas for these two days for these 48 hours
after chemo. You want that chemo to work in your body. Still take your regular supplements,
but do not do an ion cleanse, do not do coffee enemas, do not do an ion pro wave.
Then after those 48 hours, that's when you want to hit the detox therapies. That's what you wanted
me to do with your ion cleanse is your ion pro wave, your coffee enemas, maybe even up the coffee
enemas, to daily, if you haven't been doing them daily twice a day, if you've been doing them daily
to help pull that out of your body. Increasing the PMF to a little bit more frequency would
frequently would help hyperthermia if you have access to that also will help. So your back on your
regular diet, you're continuing with your supplements, you're continuing to do your rife therapies,
and you're trying to pull it out of your body so you have less damage to the body.
This protocol alone would help you, I'm sure will help reduce the symptoms, the side effects
in the chemo will help the chemo work better. You're going to take chemo, we want it to work and kill
the cancer. So this is what this is designed for. Again, if you're taking chemo and you're a patient of
ours, make sure you contact us so that we can walk you through anything else we need to do.
That's got to be your responsibility to be in the communication with us that way.
All right, hopefully this will help and we will say goodbye.